with
so many amazing things happening in the
world today
what could possibly go wrong
a giant asteroid is barreling on a
collision course with earth and
life as we know it is on the brink
after the smoke clears how do we start
over
where would we live and what
might we do differently this
is what if and here's what would happen
if there were only 1 000 people
on earth with pandemics
election scandals and civil unrest
worldwide
maybe it's time for a do-over a clean
slate
a fresh beginning with only 1
000 people left on the planet 500 women
and 500 men
where would we begin
first of all we'd need to work together
to flourish
rebuild society and repopulate the
planet
we'd need to farm hunt and help each
other succeed
sounds like a pretty good starting point
right
okay where would we find the ideal place
to build this global village
most likely a temperate region that's
not subject to
huge threats from wildlife or natural
disasters
let's stay away from the ring of fire
because earthquakes
would not help our society to rebuild we
don't want to live in an area where
malaria is common either
that's good living in the north like
canada
especially northern canada would mean
surviving intense winters
so no how about
mediterranean europe it's got a long
growing season for food and
there aren't as many natural wildlife
threats as there are in africa or
australia
now that we've found the perfect
location let's start by meeting
our basic survival needs like water food
shelter and sleep we have to take care
of them
first because if people are hungry then
socializing
learning or working won't be their main
priority slowing progress
at this stage the people who understand
how to take care of the land
would be extremely valuable they could
teach
others how to grow and harvest food
these community members would likely be
the farmers and
the other households would get rations
and
there could be hunters in the group
there should be lots of meat options
because
animal life would be flourishing around
the world without
7.8 billion humans animals would be free
to roam wherever they wanted
this would also do wonders for our
planet
[Music]
the atmospheric greenhouse gas emissions
would eventually level out and
plant life would flourish again the
earth would finally recover after the
centuries of stress
due to so many humans okay now that our
food is taken care of what about love
and belonging we are social beings and
we need
relationships this includes acceptance
at a group
family love and intimacy
if we don't meet these needs people
could become unhappy
and even bored how would we divide the
work
in our smaller pool of humans it could
be easier to
accept each other as equals as we're all
in this global village together
we could develop this society with
greater equality and
balance between the genders or we could
revert to more traditional roles for men
and women
with women of child bearing years forced
to have multiple pregnancies
similar to the handmaid's tale well
uh everything seemed to be going okay
until that point
still with not too many people to choose
from
things like love and attraction wouldn't
necessarily
dictate who you get intimate with and
those creepy arrangements
could be a thing like some licorice but
if you're
a fertile man or woman you might be
treated better because
you're responsible for increasing the
population
what the hell as we start to repopulate
the planet
there would be a need for doctors and
medical professionals
builders and construction workers would
also be helpful
teachers would be necessary but people
would likely start doing
internships to learn in such a
dramatically different society
if someone wanted to be a doctor they
could shadow the doctors for several
years and
learn from experience rather than in a
school
jobs in this new society may no longer
have any cash value and
we could see ourselves going into an
exchange economy
something like i'll help you build your
home if you teach my kids to read
going back to a cash-based society may
take some time
and with no global infrastructure to
rely upon for a supply chain
barter and trade makes sense at least in
the short term
a 1 000 person community wouldn't
guarantee a stable population
we'd need to work together to overcome
the challenges of
living without a modern society the
biggest problem
would be another disaster happening and
wiping out many of this already small
population
even a sickness could kill many people
and leave the community vulnerable
and what would happen if all humans
suddenly disappeared from earth
well that's a story for another
what if